hello everyone and welcome to another
master class from this year's Global
chess League it is
Maxima lagrav and we've seen how uh how
a masterfully undisposed of yangshis of
Duda and now you will see what he does
against Maxima Sheila grab uh you know
that Maxim always likes the uh you know
bring the weird stuff to the table he
sacrifices pieces he sacrifices The
Exchange like basically if if Maxine
played C5 and let's say G6 and Bishop to
G7 put his Bishop on this diagonal which
you will see in like maybe a night of
Sicilian or in a groomfield uh you know
that he will sacrifice something at some
point most likely a rook for a knight or
Bishop well for a night and then we will
see a very active game and here such an
opportunity presents itself and Maxim
does not act upon it and we've seen when
Maxine does very well when he does we've
seen Winnie
um well just gets destroyed when he does
it but this time he doesn't do it and it
was the best thing to do so uh it's a
really wonderful game at some point uh
Anand is really you know uh he has his
backs against the wall and then there is
only one line that he can go for but it
requires uh well uh uh a surgical
Precision to to advance from that point
so let's see what happened uh Anand has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to E4 we have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 and
now Knight to F6 Maxine goes for Petro's
defense we have Knight captures on E5
the classical variation D6 Knight to F3
and Knight captures an E4 so all very
standard here and Bishop to D3 maybe not
the the top move but for a rapid game
and it is it is uh you know gaining in
popularity as white really fun very nice
ways of how to uh prevent black from
just equalizing right away so Pawn to D5
we have castles and the bishop to E7 we
have Rook D1 uh and castles here Maxim
sacrifices a pawn so okay he he lasted
for seven moves without sacrificing same
thing but now he gives it up Bishop
counter spawn captures The Rook
characters and now Pawn to C5 so uh very
nicely done by Maxim now controlling
that D4 square and here there is a game
where Aryan played against um Dominguez
Perez he played Ponto D3 and he won a
very nice game here but here we have
Knight to C3 uh by Anand and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game
salt Knights the C6 we have Pawn to D3
B6 preparing to Finca to the light
Square bishop and Bishop to F4 by Island
Bishop to B7 by MBL uh and Rook back D1
you do not want your Rook on e4 with
that Bishop x-ray you get to work back
T1 and now Knight to D4 an excellent
Outpost for the Knight and uh also frees
up the bishop so okay you sacrificed one
Pawn but you have a lot to show for it
uh Knight captures and D4 with C
captures and now Knights the E4 uh and
of course Rook to see it's okay maximum
down upon but you can see that he is
very active he has The Bishop's pair and
also he has The Rook nicely placed on
the semi-open C file at the d-pawn makes
it a bit problematic for uh Anand to
play C3 or C4 so C2 is a backward spawn
and uh okay if you have something like
let's say Rook to C6 Queen D7 Rook if
the C8 you will uh probably collect this
Pawn at some point so Pawn to F3 as
strengthening in the center a little bit
and now Queen to D7 we've Queen to D2
and now Rook the C6 getting the Rook
into the game now The Rook can be
shifted to the king side to help out
with the attack and also you can double
up on the C file Anna plays Queen to F2
and now we have Pawn to F5 chasing away
tonight from such an active Square
Knight G3 and now Bishop to H4 and Maxim
putting even more pressure on onan's
position this still being a weak point
now the Knight cannot move either so
still there is uh there is quite um
enough compensation for that sacrificed
Pawn so Queen to D2 getting out of the
pin and now Pawn to H6 Maxine prepare
spawn to G5 we have Queen to B4 and Rook
the C5 not allowing Anand to have any
uh control over the board especially not
to offer a queen trade or anything uh
and uh of course if uh the the trade
Bishop for night ever happens then you
also have to worry about Rook the E7 so
uh Rook the C5 stops all of that uh Rook
D2 preparing to bring the other Rook
into the game but also just getting Rook
off of that E1 square and pawn to G5 we
have Bishop to E5 and now Pawn to F4
attacking the Knight and G3 uh and this
is where the the magic really happens
now you can't really play Knight to E4
because then the bishop hangs the only
uh piece defending that Bishop is The
Rook so here Bishop captures on D4 is
played uh Anand wins uh another pawn and
now uh Maxim went into a really really
long thing here best for you is to just
play F characters and G3 and uh give up
uh The Exchange and this is what I was
talking about at the beginning of the
video Maxim started sacrificing but now
where he should have continued in his
style uh with I mean this is this is
vintage Maxim he doesn't go for here you
would see Bishop captures on C5 giving
up the Rook for the Bishop B captors
Queen captures and now even G captures
on H2 with check King captures and now
Rook F7 not allowing some Rook D7
lifting and you have uh the the bishop
pair you also have the queen you have
the Rook I mean you you would have very
nice compensation for the uh for the
sacrifice exchange okay it's not even an
exchange uh you have
a rook for two Bishops so okay the black
king is a bit more open but uh this is
definitely the way to go however after
this bishop captures on D4 move Maxim
played Ponte A5 and it's an extremely
tricky move uh and Anand needs to
proceed with like I said surgical
Precision in order to gain any sort of
Advantage here uh and he does he plays
Queen to B3 with check the problem with
capturing and B6 is that of course Queen
captures on D4 comes with checks so you
cannot allow that and okay you could
even uh let's say King to H1 uh okay the
bishop is hanging also have to worry
about Queen to G6 it's a tricky line but
let's say Bishop captures an F3 because
you will also capture on G3 so G
counters have captors and G3 Queen
captures and H6 let's say and now Rook
the C7 uh just uh guarding the the
seventh Rank and if anyone is better
here it is definitely black however
Anand plays Queen to B3 with check with
Bishop to D5 and now uh of course you
don't play Queen to B3 check without
checking what happens if Bishop to D5
but Anand of course check that any
played Pawn to see for immediately and
it seems like such a weird move to play
uh because what if Maxim just captures
it the bishop and D4 will still be
hanging well that's exactly what Maxim
does Bishop captures on C4 attacks the
queen also threatens the bishop on D4
but this is what Anand prepared Queen to
C3 and remember ever since uh Maxim
played the this A5 move uh Anand is
playing every move is a top engine move
and now finally Rook to D5 showing that
the Rook belonged on the D5 Square not
the light Square bishop and now there is
only one way for Anand to really seize
the initiative here feel free to pause
the video and try to find this idea
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh finding this
spectacular move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
I'm not going to tell you what it is
first I'm going to show what happens if
Queen captures on C4 because this is the
move that uh well simply comes to mind
uh and it's very hard not to play this
movie because if Queen captures on C4
you win a piece and also you pin The
Rook so you don't have to worry about
Rook catras on D4 the problem with this
is B5 this is how you win uh the bishop
on D4 and after Queen B3 trying to keep
the tension here A4 that's the problem
after the queen moves finally you play
Rook captures on D4 okay the Knight will
move now you're gonna play G4 and the
black gets a whole lot out of the
position so Anand did not play that I
don't play the move I'm sure you all
found Bishop to F6 and it's such a such
a top level move a threatening Rook to
E7 and then just completely annihilating
the black king so how can how can Maxime
get out of this well F captures on G3
this simply has to be played but now not
reacting to the bishop on c for hanging
Rook the E7 right away and now you have
to play Queen to 5 to even remotely stay
in the game Maxime doesn't find it the
point is after Queen F5 okay D cap
present C4 attacks The Rook uh and now
it doesn't matter that the bishop on F6
is hanging because the Rook is also
hanging so this is why this D captures
on C4 is so powerful Rook to D7 let's
say we trade captures captures Now Pawn
to H3 and okay it's a very nice white
will always be better but maybe black
can do something about it for the moment
the bishop it looks pretty silly there
on H4 it's basically a pawn uh but those
were your chances after Queen to D6
there is no stopping on and he plays
Queen a rook to G7 with check and now uh
the the windmill action occurs you have
to play King Day cheat only move and now
okay Anna repeats one to Rook to F7
check King to Jade Rook to G7 checking
to h8 and now Rook the F7 with check uh
this is the second best or maybe even
it's the first best it's hard to say if
you allow the engine to run indefinitely
the engine will say okay this is best or
a bishop to E7 to be best both moves you
will play it's only a matter of in what
order point is that after Bishop to E7
now you are still threatening or sorts
of nasty discoveries but also you are
threatening to win material and here you
would get captures with check King the
H1 and Rook captures on D3 attacking the
White Queen and now you trade everything
off Bishop captures and these six Rook
captures on C3 now Bishop captures an f8
to defend the Rook here and the black
Rook is still hanging here so Rook to D3
now B3 Chase with the bishop and now
finally Rook to C1
and white will uh well be very very
close to winning if not straight out
winning the problem is there's not much
you can do if Rook to G Bishop to G3 of
course you want to stop King captures on
H2 because now you also have some mate
threats uh Rook the D7 uh and now
there's really not much more you can do
here uh once the bishop moves you will
play Rook to C8 Checkmate and that's
pretty much it so here you would have to
trade let's say Bishop C4 captures
captures and now let's say Bishop
captures an H6 uh of course completely
uh winning uh for white you will still
have to work for it because the king for
the moment is stuck here uh but it's not
um it's not very difficult to to free it
from there since you are of the exchange
but okay in the game Rook to F7 check
was played uh and now after King to Jade
Anan does not repeat he plays Bishop to
E7 now now it's a little bit different
Maxine plays G captures an HD with
checking to H1 and now Rook captures on
F7 he gives up the queen for some
material here Bishop capture Rook
captures on D6 and queen captures on C4
uh keep spinning the The Rook on this
diagonal we have Bishop to G3 now still
of course Maxim is hoping for some sort
of a Checkmate um if the the Rooks can
somehow be deployed on the E file maybe
if Rook T1 can be played uh you will get
the Checkmate on and but that's a long
way from here Queen to G4 uh we have
Bishop to F4 and now uh Pawn to G3
chasing away the bishop and of course
now you will free the king uh Bishop to
E5 we have rooked the E1 attacks the
bishop Bishop captures on B2 and now
even Rook the E6 not bothering with this
because there's no rush you can always
capture it at some point uh probably mvl
will give a check and then you're gonna
capture it Rook captures on D3 Rook
captures on H6 and now Rook D characters
on F3 so uh very very close are those
pieces the still the white king but uh
so is unan's Queen to mvl skin Queen
captures and G5 check uh Bishop goes
back to G7 and now Rook captures on B6
uh we have Rook to F2 uh okay Anand
prolonged the the capture of the H2 Pawn
so now Maxim defends it uh if he can get
uh somehow uh the other Rook to the
first rank is game over for Anna and the
butt again quite a few moves to reach
that Rook the B8 which check King to H7
and now Queen to H for with check we
have King to G6 Queen to E4 with check
we have Rook 7 to F5 and now Rook the B6
with the check and it was in this
position on move 48 that Maxim vashiella
grav resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so it's
truly a a brilliant brilliant
Masterpiece by Ananda
um a maxim played a brilliant game also
but he gave Anand that one one
opportunity that required surgical
Precision Anand of course found it and
uh there was just no way out uh for
maxim to save this game uh here you
resign because whatever you play let's
say block with the bishop Bishop to F6
just G4 uh wins the rook and then you
are down too much material uh if you try
something else like King to G5 then
Queen to H4 is mating one I try King to
F7 not much better just Queen to E6
check will be amazing two King to f8 and
Rook to beat with check his Checkmate so
really nothing to do here of course I
have to Rook the B6 check and Maxine uh
resigned and a spectacular victory for
vishana on board one for his team so if
you guys are interested in what happened
on the other boards uh for this uh in
this matchup let me just quickly check
uh so okay Anand steam lost uh the
abroad Mumba Masters have defeated the
Genghis Grand Masters Anand one on board
one but grishock defeated Rapport on
board too and uh uh Adriana Valley
defeated cotton sweeley on board five so
there we have it those are the the other
results if you have any other favorites
do do use hashtag suggestion and I will
very gladly show them until then really
hope you guys enjoyed it and I'm just
showing everyone how it's done I mean
what what are you gonna do he he he he
uh he's a two-time World rapid champion
and he's just you know enjoying himself
here that's right once again really hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
ABC's of chess openings for kids an
anonymous person uh Doug and Repcon when
bentus and uh Dan McCormick and James
Eugene Cashman for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day